[Music]
Frankie
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and after the
incredible news that Brandon Routh would
be returning to the role of Superman in
the CW's upcoming crossover event crisis
on Infinite Earths we actually have some
news that in my opinion breaks the
internet that is that Kevin Conroy will
be playing a live-action version of
Batman in the upcoming mega event Kevin
Conroy is undoubtedly the voice of
Batman and he's arguably given the most
iconic portrayal of the character who
performances that have spanned film TV
shows and games the guy isn't absolute
legend and by far the most accurate
depiction of Batman we've ever had but
he's never had his chance to portray the
Caped Crusader in a live-action
adaptation until now it's been a request
from fans for years to see Conroy
actually play him on screen but with him
gradually getting older and older it
always seemed like it was never going to
happen however there's a perfect role
for him these days and that is the elder
version of Bruce Wayne from the Batman
Beyond the universe the news that he
would be playing this version of Batman
was announced at the Television Critics
Association press tour and it's honestly
one of the best pieces of fan service
that I've ever seen the more and more I
hear about this event the more and more
incredible that I think it's going to be
and this pretty much just takes the cake
I'm sure you can all hear Kevin Conroy
voice in your head all the time and it
really can't be overstated how important
his portrayal was to the countless
iterations of Batman that have come
after him he will always be Batman for
many and I'm glad that he's finally
getting a chance to make his mark in a
live action before
the mega event is due to start on
December the 8th and I really can't
express how hyped I am for it obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
news and what you hope to see in the
show
comment below and let me know and if you
want to see the breakdown of the news
that bran and Ravis returning then make
sure you watch that video would you be
linked at the end it covers everything
you need to know about the upcoming CW
show so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me on Twitter about this
news or movies TV shows comics games
just anything in general then make sure
you follow me at definition YT it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
over there after this this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you